JENNY BROWN: Today,
we're talking
about access management, free
skill building, and "Call
of Duty."
I'm Jenny, and welcome to "This
Week in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
To minimize management effort
and the risk of an oversight,
IT administrators often prefer
centralized access control.
To achieve this, we've released
IAM database authentication
for Cloud SQL and MySQL
into general availability.
With IAM database
authentication,
administrators can use cloud
identity and access management
to govern not only
administrative access, but also
connection access for
their MySQL databases.
Check out the blog for more
specifics and how to get
started.
Earlier this year, we launched
the Google Cloud Skills
Challenge, which provides
30 days of free access
to training to build your cloud
knowledge and an opportunity
to earn skill badges that
showcase your Google Cloud
competencies.
Now, we're adding a native
app development track
to the skills challenge
for cloud developers
who want to learn to build
serverless web apps and Google
Assistant applications on
Google Cloud using Cloud Run
and Firebase.
Millions of people view
action-packed esports.
And a new revolutionary
project that we're
working on with Call
of Duty League using
BigQuery and Looker just made
that action a lot better.
ActivStat, an entirely new
capability for esports,
brings fans, players,
and commentators
the power of competitive
statistics in real time.
Call of Duty League will roll
out ActivStat during the 2021
season.
So check out the blog
post for more details.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.